i'm just like living life and whatever
happens happens
well i'll tell you what happened
kourtney kardashian is dating her
longtime friend travis barker
and now a source tells e.t her ex scott
disick
is totally supportive of it at the end
of the day i mean you just want to be
happy
you want to be content you want to be
comfortable quote
scott hasn't been reacting much to
courtney and travis dating
it's always a bit of an adjustment when
one of them is dating someone new
but at the end of the day he obviously
wants courtney to be happy
and they're focused on co-parenting
together everyone has to handle their
co-parenting situation in their own
style but that's how
it should be and love is love and i'm so
proud of
them it's a beautiful thing to get along
with each other and for your kids to see
that
of course scott and court share three
kiddos together eleven-year-old mason
eight-year-old penelope and six-year-old
reign
and the two have managed to stay close
and co-parent ever since their
high-profile breakup in 2015.
i mean i think we've been through so
much in so many things and to hear her
be proud of me means you know a ton to
me and since they're split
the pairs had their fair share of other
romances
most notably the push founder's
relationship with eunice benjamin
and scott's relationship with sofia
richie
2020 was my year of being like
letting everything go and just like no
fear oh and the 37 year old recently
rang in the new year with 19 year old
amelia hamlin in mexico a source tells
e.t that he is still dating amelia and
having fun with her as for court's new
romance with the blink 182 drummer
news first broke that the two were a
thing on sunday
and our source says courtney's family is
super supportive of the relationship
and loves travis he has been a family
friend for
such a long time and courtney has been
single for a while
so they're all very happy for her and
think this is the healthiest
relationship that she could be in
thank you travis has two children 17
year old landon and fifteen-year-old
alabama whom he shares with his ex-wife
shayna mulkler and a source previously
told et
that travis's kids totally get along
with courts
adding that the 41 year old reality star
and the 45 year old musician
live on the same block and quote things
are super easy between them because they
know each other so well
and just click and get one another
you